Rick Stroud who covers the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers who joins us now Rick thank
you for joining us I appreciate your
time thank you all right the Jameis
Winston situation where it looks like he
could be suspended for three games how
surprised are you not surprised at all I
mean I think the NFL you know was likely
to do this just because of the you know
the liability in a way and and you know
his history look we don't know after
eight months of the forensic
investigation what they found what they
learned right it's a he said she's that
situation maybe but we know what he came
into the league with and you know I just
think that you know I don't expect them
to appeal it I think that it could have
been more games potentially it still
potentially could be more if he doesn't
what I understand doesn't accomplish
certain things you know if I was going
to require of him that they likely won't
announce but you know this is this is
the thing that the Bucs feared you know
when you take a guy number one overall
and he has the history he had I mean
remember he went to the league two weeks
before the draft on his own and sat down
with the Commissioner and spent five
hours on Park Avenue trying to convince
the NFL the day would have no trouble
with him you know during his pro career
and here he is why why won't he appeal
this because it judging from what is
being said it's it's it's he said she
said about this incident and did he have
a teammate there or a friend who was
there as well to witness this yeah well
I mean the appeal is still it's still
potential but from what I understand you
won't in there and I think the reason is
that he wants to move forward there's
also a financial component to this you
know next year if he does play for a
fifth year club option at 20 million
dollars that's significantly less than
what he makes now so you're talking
about you know maybe $125,000 forfeiture
of checks that's not the main thing
though I think I think primarily he
wants to get it behind him we know these
appeals haven't gone well they're
usually not the appeal of the decision
it usually becomes whether or not the
NFL has the right to you know to med out
punishment and the NFL has won in the
court so you know this is something that
there's been a lot of dialogue between
league between Janice's representatives
I think is something that they're not
happy about but but comfortable enough
to be committed to getting it behind him
and and moving forward because Tampa
knew about this and they decided to pick
up his option for that fifth year that's
just under 21 million dollars that was
that surprising at all that they were
they rolling the dice on this Rick not
so much Dan because the the 21 million
dollars is guaranteed only against
injury so if he gets to March no matter
what happens this season and he can pass
a physical the Bucs are not committed to
honoring that contract is just is a club
option so there wasn't a lot of risk
financially he's kind of a no-brainer
there's still a chance that he wouldn't
get suspended at that point so they went
ahead and picked it up but it really
doesn't mean anything
how is he viewed locally in Tampa well I
mean I think it was mixed certainly when
he came into the league he's won over
some fans in Tampa because his
production now you know here's the thing
he's won 18 games in three years for a
number one overall pick he was on some
bad football teams that's usually the
case but that's not a lot of winning Dan
and you know three and ten last year you
had some injuries so you know people
were still waiting for him to sort of
you know honor his promise as a number
one overall pick but the the reaction
has been interesting I mean I think you
have you know just fans being fans who
will attack the NFL say there's no
evidence want to see the evidence you
know and they confuse this with a court
of law you know this is a business this
is something that was collectively
bargain the league doesn't need you know
a criminal charge or a civil complaint I
mean so it's you know I think people are
still caught in fandom wanting to know
why the NFL can do this and wanting due
process that doesn't necessarily exist
but let me again
think about Jameis Winston's history
going back to Florida State I think it's
pretty obvious why they did it we're
talking to Rick Stroud covers the Tampa
Bay Buccaneers he's he's got an odd
personality Rick how would you describe
that personality with Jameis Winston
I would say that you know he's
charismatic as hell
he's extremely in it's intense when it
comes to football he loves football he
spends a lot of time working on his
craft some of it is a little contrived
at times you know I think he tries too
hard to to play a role
I think his charisma is natural the
position the quarterback doesn't require
you to do anything more than then
perform at times and you know everybody
on the staff has told them hey Jameis
less is more with you you know you have
everything but but there is this you
know this other side that we've seen
that at minimum isn't very smart right I
mean things he has done
you can chalk up in college maybe but
these are serious accusations when you
have to you know assault like sexual
assault like allegations and I know
they're allegations and I believe in you
know in the court system and all that
and he he went through it at Florida
State and was never charged it's just
there's something missing there there's
some disconnect there that you would put
yourself in positions where you could
forfeit
perhaps your entire career I mean let's
let's go forward and say he comes back
doesn't play particularly well maybe
they win six or seven games with him as
a starter you know is a team gonna give
him twenty million dollars and then you
know at that point or a hundred million
dollars which is what you'd want to do
with a franchise quarterback because of
his history I just think he's
jeopardized too much Rick great stuff
thank you for joining us story we will
obviously keep an eye on and we
appreciate your time let's Rick Stroud
covers the Buccaneers for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
you